caleb dunn
served as a combat medic specialist in
the us army before becoming an emergency
medical technician
in new york city tales of his combat
record and solid reputation
meant that he was eventually picked up
by the shd and it wasn't long before he
was recruited
months after the outbreak that brought
down new york city dunn
and fellow agent and friend kaminsky
have been activated
and are investigating a potential
resurgence among the previously
dismantled last man battalion
the lmb leader charles bliss is dead and
the surviving forces have been scattered
by the division and jtf
however months later reports were
beginning to show an increase of l b
activity
it seemed as if they were starting to
rebuild and one of the largest concerns
was the noticeable increase in weapons
and technology they suddenly had at
their disposal
so agents dun and kaminsky made it their
mission to find and put a stop to this
new supply
their initial intel suggests that it's
kinah but he has since fallen out with
the lmb
after abandoning them during an attack
by the division and has since left the
city long ago
regardless they've been given some
information on a warehouse that is of
particular interest to the lmb
and this could be potentially where
they're storing the weapons or better
yet where their unknown supplier is
hiding out
with a backup of jtf support they plan
an assault on the heavily guarded
warehouse
sweeping through the building dunn
focuses on clearing the lower levels
while kaminsky secures the upper floors
rapidly eliminating lmb
troops before they have time to react
dunn receives a call over his earpiece
from kaminsky
primary target located dunn confirms
and immediately starts making his way to
his location but before he is able to
catch up
there is a commotion and the comms cut
out
breaking a window done quickly and
carefully peers into an office
there before him he finds kaminsky
standing in the middle of the room
with a woman dressed in black holding a
knife to his throat
as dunn attempts to talk her down she
begins slowly backing out of the room
towards the door
all while keeping the knife pressed up
closely against kaminsky's throat
then just before she exits through the
door she swiftly thrusts the blade
straight into kaminsky's neck
and then once again into his lower back
with her immobilized
she takes off quickly down the hallway
dunn opens fire but it's too late
she has already managed to slip away he
promptly drops to the ground
and tries to tend to his friend's wounds
but ultimately he begins to realize
there is nothing he can do
he gathers himself together and sits
quietly with kaminsky staying with him
as he succumbs to his mortal wounds
and draws his last breath
dunn goes to visit an informant who has
loose ties to the lmb
hoping that he may have some information
about the identity of this woman
he began to realize during their
altercation that she wasn't just another
street thug trying to take advantage of
the situation
she was fast well-trained and knew
exactly what she was doing
arriving at the apartment building dunn
finds the informant
his throat has been slit and he's been
left to bleed out on the chair
using isaac's technology he was able to
recreate the events of what had happened
it was the same woman she had gotten to
the informant first
looking closely at the echo projection
he tried to find anything that could
hint at her identity
but her face doesn't match anything in
the database so she can't be a rogue shd
agent
but given the state of the country if
she isn't an agent
what is she then suddenly isaac pipes up
listing off a number of trace chemicals
that have been found at the scene
copper sulfate chlorine dioxide
polydimethylsiloxane
these are all substances that are used
in water treatment
contacting feylau through the comms dun
asks for the location of the nearest
water treatment facility
he knows it's a long shot but it's all
he has at this stage
staying at the treatment plant for over
three hours dunn hopes to find something
anything after some time has passed
again
isaac beeps it has just registered some
sort of transmission
searching dunn eventually finds a
military-grade fiber-optic cable
and as he begins to follow the line to
see where it's coming from isaac alerts
him again to some movement nearby
swiftly ducking for cover behind some
hedges he lays motionless just off to
the side of the main path
two figures are approaching it was her
and she was with an agent
isaac scanned his identity agent ike
ronson
he must be rogue thought done but for
some reason his watch was still orange
rather than confronting them then and
there dunn decides to remain hidden
instead he wants to first find out where
the cable leads to and secondly who this
person really is
he did hear her talking about the lmb
and she has an agent working with her
and possibly others there is most
definitely something bigger going on
here
his search of the cable eventually leads
him down a manhole and into the
underground service tunnels
there dunn finds a room and by gaining
access to the door control panel he
accidentally sets off an alarm protocol
figuring he should have at least a few
minutes before the unknown woman returns
he decides to proceed onwards and
swiftly enters
his suspicions are correct she is very
obviously well connected and a part of
something much bigger at play
there are maps of manhattan the eastern
coast and there are photos of division
agents all over the walls
the map information points towards some
sort of large-scale operation
focusing on new york and philadelphia
on top of the desk there are division
watches once owned by shd agents
dunn could only imagine what had
happened to them but he wasn't able to
think about this for long
bursting into the room and firing a
vector the woman had returned
rapidly returning fire done advanced
towards her position
and promptly knocked the weapon out of
her hand in that same motion
she grabbed hold of his arm and using
his own momentum threw him over his
shoulder
causing him to come crashing down on top
of the desk while he lay on the ground
quickly trying to regain his feet she
unsheathed her knife and moved to stand
threateningly above him
dunn immediately swung his legs around
taking her feet out from underneath her
they both hurriedly rose to their feet
blocking eyes they stared at each other
face to face
when suddenly she let out a victorious
smile and bolted from the room
unable to pursue her due to a bullet
that had struck his leg during the fight
and puzzled by her unusual behavior
dunn's eyes rapidly darted around the
room
he located a monitor with a countdown
timer on it
in 11 seconds something was going to
happen and based on her reaction
he more than likely didn't want to be
there when it did
moving as fast as he could he made his
way quickly out of the room up through
the tunnels
and back to the surface he knew he had
to gain as much distance as possible
from the timer
so he continued to run as far as he
could when suddenly from behind him
the compound exploded launching him into
the air
surrounded by burning debris he is
located and helped to his feet by some
jtf officers who'd been sent by fey
to check up on him
back in the shd base of operations dunn
has been patched up by medical staff
his isaac was completely destroyed by
the blast and nothing he witnessed has
been able to be extracted from it
but he knew what he'd seen lists and
photos of agents
safe houses operational plans she
they knew everything about the shd
he discussed with faye his plans to make
his way to philadelphia
the one other city that was clearly
marked out on the map
although the passing of time is helping
to heal the loss of his friend
he plans to find out what this woman was
up to and when the time is right
avengers death
there may not be a lot happening in the
division universe while we wait for news
on all of these new updates
games and books i've been talking about
but i'm not in the mood to take a break
and put the channel on hold just yet
and there isn't really any other games
that interest me right now so i'm using
this opportunity to catch up on a number
of subjects that i never got around to
at the time
and the extremist malice series is one
that is well overdue
if you weren't aware this is based on
the series of three division comic books
that came out at the start of the
division 2. you can find these on
darkhorse.com
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]